hey how's it going my name is Peter Pam
oh boy can I not wait to play more let's
start right now I would be like well I'm
dead
well I'm dead I might as well this
well it's a good thing he sucks at
aiming Jesus Christ come on me Sean oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] nowhere do you should get shot
right
come on [ __ ] go
oh that's what I'm talking about
you're fine
hope the shortcut was worth it oh we got
a bandage sure summer it's called
bandage what sir you'll be all right see
I'm gonna get you home okay
vapenation we did it that was good
that's some good shin I have a feeling
we're gonna see them again why are they
so eager to kill us we just want to go
away like come on you're not far like if
they love us
let us go just like that zombie
honestly the walkers in this game sounds
exactly like what I have my dog hey
buddy how you doing
tougher to monitor it I found no
misplace of I'll bark when I was just a
couple of boats anchored to appear they
had some supplies just sitting out and a
normal caught me I don't think she was
going to but she let me go no Greg's
dead weight normal let you go why'd she
let you go she took pity on me I told
her my family was starving and that was
enough
oh it's like you used of all the pity
she's got ha ha ha I thought we could
just hide this stuff on the ferry but
Greg II didn't think it was safe well he
was right wasn't he
damn right you should have there we go
Thanks
oh he's ready clear back can I get their
[ __ ] machete please you're not
looking so good
nice Thanks what the Sam we're gonna get
you home keep her focused you sure your
house is safe I think so it's kept us
alive for the past um however long it's
been it's hard to find that's our only
real defense though will you good lucky
right now I'll take whatever we can get
hey nice jacket man good never mind
[ __ ] or I got it hi Michelle another
hipster how about that
I really hate hipsters in this game no
they should leave the house walkers are
trouble people are worse didn't listen
it wasn't your fault
Greg it's not what he's gonna think
we'll help him understand sir
don't worry about entertainment stay out
of a bad situation
I don't know how am I supposed to tell
my daughter but Greg I'm his Lehmann I
don't know if I can let me an alto hey
why did you dad let you out in their
world middle with walkers and [ __ ] with
your only two daughter and son like
don't [ __ ] get hit Sam Sam wake up
I've heerd sons face become a pancake
like that's not that's not
summers I'm in a bad day
No Oh bad ass
what holy [ __ ] oops
god damn there's so many of them
set a trap that's the house I live you
found it
what's going on why is she not walking
there we go by that I'm a fat fat fat
fat F F at a bat bat bat bat bat oh you
got [ __ ]
what is that has what it how did we get
in almost there almost home what all the
walkers go should be yourself come on
Sam don't [ __ ] move one more step
we're not gonna hurt you
we just want to help this girl Sam yeah
maybe you should have looked Jesus
Christ
oh shoot
Sam still alive but she won't be for
long unless you let us maybe you shot
her
come in here and kill everyone I can't
take that risk
so just put Sam down and we Sam trusted
me to get her home how did you think I
found this place yeah your dumb [ __ ]
I'm doing this for her not you well I
don't give a [ __ ] you [ __ ] dude
what's your [ __ ] problem man they're
right at their back
well then a nice little souvenir
wait that's all it takes a wall a
[ __ ] wall all this time I can't
escape zombies what is going on your
sister's heart
yeah she's fine we're gonna fix right
this is really really bad we're gonna
help her okay okay what's your name
it's James okay James you got a first
aid kit kind of get it fast what do you
mean kind of what is it like at school
like one oh that looks bad
whatever we're gonna do we got to do it
fast well she got shot in the shoulder
now you gotta be a [ __ ] to die by being
shut of mini vodka what are you doing
with that Sam Sam I got you I'm here I
need to clean the wound it's good that
[ __ ] hurt so much to do that [ __ ]
[ __ ] there's too much blood so what do
we do you get the plier you get the pie
here we've got the buyer and the
aspirator aspirator yeah [ __ ] kitty
oh I know it's is that the cleaner nose
man all these parts to clean wounds is
so disgusting goddammit okay fine here
we go that was fine didn't even flinch
you got some tape hand me back
not gonna lie this is gonna really
[ __ ] hurt that's fine
I do this every day don't hold her down
you two we got him
I've only done this once so
oh man it's barbecue tonight boys get
away from her
John are you doing to my daughter
we just life with that you want to do
this instead all right
didn't think so James let me I mean it
looks fine come on oh god not again it
sounds just like sea sling bacon it
sounds just like bacon
what the [ __ ] we'll never be able to
look at bacon again every minute
goddamnit disgusting is that is she
going to make it okay you know sir I
can't
my poor cement the bleeding stopped
that's what matters
she's fine don't worry about it tell me
yeah what happened uh so like we met
this girl and like this fairy and then
that bullet was supposed to hit me
God Sam instead that it should be you
lying on this table oh you did not just
say that old man I don't care who you
are you don't talk to me Shawn like that
look at me
I don't know the hell you are but dad
dad what are you looking at oh oh
Oh
No
I'm so sorry what do you mean Greg
didn't come back with them Shawn me
Shawn listen you gotta pinch yourself
when that happens
are you pinched your forehead that's a
random space listen it's me Shawn it's
an illusion why is my nose so [ __ ]
red god damn it let's not pick it up how
about that okay we did pick it up well
what you gonna do I'm really glad we
continue playing this cuz this is a lot
more interesting than the first one I
gotta say it picked up speed it's cool
I'm into it
I hope you are as well that's just for
good luck
don't tell mark Collett Elodie
your girls in here yeah ladies
I'm gonna guess no look for evidence of
what happened to your daughters okay
let's look at the painting I guess that
is a tiger that doesn't really tell me
[ __ ] what about the trout
you mean the Tao CH then to which Oh
touch Oh
well you got it a little something there
on yourself Michonne to be honest who
talking seems to have my belly I don't
know what it is but the pressure is
relieved and it feels good
no I didn't fart it's not what I said
the only the only thing I think about
when there's this a disasters like if
there was walkers and [ __ ] like that is
like will there still be internet that's
all I care about will be Internet still
be alive because if the internet goes
down then like what's the [ __ ] point
you know what I mean
I watched Cloverfield to yesterday I
highly recommend it it's a it's very
good I'm not gonna tell you anything but
it's also bad survival I guess go watch
it you'll enjoy it
but I was thinking the same thing like
how can you survive without internet
like how can you survive without quoting
Pyatt you know what I mean what am i
what am I doing here you know there
so is this after she the TV show because
she seemed to know about the trick of of
the two walkers before
and I'm starting to think that you know
there's two timelines that we play in
the earlier one in the later one it's
interesting
do a little dance make it a little love
get down tonight get down the night
sorry that song was not appropriate for
the situation redial
I don't have a I don't have a phone
that's weird I mean I have a cellphone
but I don't have a phone to my house
yeah how do you miss that
because I'm scared of people calling me
kitchen knife like we found a lot of
evidence I don't know what else to tell
you
okay
y'all know me still same OG but I've
been lucky there was a walker right
[ __ ] there geez suitcase
they were packing to get out they
practice on meat we have this alive now
it's calling what the [ __ ]
and just answer it
hello Michelle it's Donna Donna I've
been trying to get ahold of their dad
are the girls with you know something
bad happen oh my god it's blood
everywhere
Donna where was he taking the girls here
where are they
I don't where we stay where you are I'm
coming to you
alright proce gonna have to end that
episode there lysippos ode is up next
it's up already go check it out let me
know what you think thank you for
leaving and like and as always stay
awesome breasts stay awesome bros stay
awesome bros stay awesome bros stay
awesome I'm gonna do a pass